police prochain
tu as un truc sous la botte ouais j'ai
vu ça
est associé avec votre interpellation ce
matin combien de temps être suspendu six
semaines sans rémunération
on a six mois de retard sur le paiement
des charges d'accord je trouverais
intrigue
j'ai prévu un rendez vous avec andré
mardi intéresse il a un truc à proposer
je détiens en cours
qu'est ce qu'on fait là pognon
qui est j'étais un flic en service mais
maintenant je suis à vue aux civils
fauchés la gagner le droit se fait
rétribuer à notre vraie valeur
tu as été tuyautés lawrence fogelman il
faut qu'on soit prêt demain soir
faut que j'y aille si tu le fais tu fais
pour toucher du fric et chez toi je suis
pas contre l'idée de piquer du fric à
dealer ce que je préfère en langue c'est
manger une fourmi rouge elle serait plus
vite
il ya un tas de malades qui sévissent
tous un peu bizarre
on va faire un voyage en terre inconnue
que la fête arrange
[Musique]
longtemps je laisse tomber quand je